given that you guys started this this
venture to try to like change the
culture not only of women's sports but I
think probably culture at Large
how big of a lift did it feel like to
set out on that and then how crucial was
it to have your sort of well-known
Partners in this like Serena and Alexis
and Eva and Jessica and Jen and
everybody
well it was incredible to get the
support from all of those friends and
and it was it was really moving when
people came on board because it wasn't
obvious and we got a lot of no's before
we got yeses and um it I feel like I
didn't realize what a big lift it was
and that might have stopped me from
doing it if I understood how how hard it
was going to be
um and I feel lucky that I had that kind
of ignorance or optimism that of course
this will work out I believed in it so
much I believed in it because these
players are the best players in the
world and the most popular sport in the
world and I thought there's no way that
you don't provide greater accessibility
and this isn't the the biggest hit yeah
of course right have you been following
what Ryan Reynolds and rexham have been
doing is there space for a Hollywood
Crossover with football have you guys
talked about your Journeys at all yeah
I've been lucky enough to talk to him
about his journey and he's so
inspirational for what he's done with
ruxum and they have a women's team also
and so we have talked about kind of
having having some friendly matches at
some point that would be incredible who
is I think it was Julie at the end so
when they when you guys win a
championship Wembley is the goal I feel
like that would be a good venue for for
these teams to to meet each other what
does it mean to you that you know at the
end of the documentary we see that
there's other women owners coming on
board you know given that that was maybe
part of what you guys set out to do is
to inspire that what does it mean to you
that you're accomplishing the things
that you set out to do you're raising
the value of the team the sponsorship
money is going up like the goals are are
slowly being met the that's been the
most uh exciting thing we want to share
our Playbook so that other people can
learn from what we did well and what
mistakes we made and you know have a
foot forward when they do their own
um Endeavors to build teams and we're
seeing it already being replicated in
other cities and it's it's not
replicated but taking kind of certain
aspects of our model and then adapting
it to their own cities so that's been
really exciting how fun is this for you
personally I've got little kids I can't
wait to bring them to one of these games
what has it been like for you and your
family the best is seeing all the kids
of all genders
being rabid fans for these women I think
that that's the dream I mean
clearly female athletes are so important
for girls to see but it's also important
for all kids to see female athletes I
mean as a girl growing up I idolize male
athletes like we shouldn't only be able
to identify with people who look like us
and greatness is is
something that we can admire and aspire
to no matter what form it comes in
finally Before I Let You Go um do you
have any thoughts on the writer strike
have you had any have you had any
projects that have gotten pushed back
because of this no I I fully support the
writers and fully support the strike and
you know we have a very changing
industry and contracts need to change
because our industry is changing so
rapidly
[Music]